alright so the job is to debate the
question of whether or not general
relativity or quantum mechanics is more
fundamental it's not necessarily obvious
what that means not obvious to me I take
it to mean something like we all believe
we both believe some of us believe that
there is a correct theory of the world
and when we find it that theory will
reproduce the empirical successes of
both general relativity and quantum
mechanics and the appropriate regimes
and the question of fundamental mistake
Intuit firry sort of keep the
fundamental structure of quantum
mechanics exactly intact and general
relativity will be emergent from that or
will the basic principles of GR be right
there front and center and quantum
mechanics is somehow shunted off into a
corner clearly we don't know the answer
so a matter of taste isn't all but many
matters of taste and we'll have to see
unless a retro puzzle person in the room
can tell us what the final answer is
going to be but I'm on the side of
quantum mechanics being more fundamental
that's not because I don't like general
relativity I wrote a book on it you can
all buy it
jeanna relativity is awesome I said in
the book and I still think it is the
most beautiful physical theory ever
invented but in the contest between
general relativity and quantum mechanics
it's not a fair fight right my side is
sort of the obvious straightforward
choice in the debate which is not meters
right I'm actually not making a value
judgment are kumin yet I'm just saying
that if you were that what happened in
physics is there was everything that
happened before Isaac Newton and then
there was classical mechanics and then
there was quantum mechanics these are
the three phases of the history of
physics and general relativity is a
classical theory it's a classical field
theory there is a degree of freedom
there's the metric tensor field all over
space-time it has you can write in a
face based formulation with a conjugate
momentum observables are every function
of phase space you can imagine and all
the apparatus of classical mechanics
just with this particular Hamiltonian or
Lagrangian whereas quantum mechanics
says the role is the entirely different
thing there's the uncertainty principle
rather than face pace we have helper
space and so
when you were faced with any other
classical theory of the world you would
quantize it and it wouldn't be a battle
between that classical theory and
quantum mechanics it would be subsumed
so the question is why would you not
think that that was true about general
relativity and the answer I think well
for one thing there's two answers the
the very short answers would be hard to
see no sorry I need to add one more
point to why it's obviously true the
generality is less fundamental because
it's hard to imagine how it could be
more fundamental general relativity
gives you an equation Einstein's
equation with the Einstein tensor on the
left hand side and the energy metric
that's on the right hand side general
attempt to be more fundamental with some
how mean there was a classical
space-time metric could still evade that
equation and it's utterly unclear what
the right-hand side should be what the
source of gravity would be if the metric
were left classical somehow if the
metric were not straightforwardly
quantized if you had a source that was
in a superposition a macroscopic object
misoo position of two different
positions where's the gravitational
field pointing is it in between is it to
one or the other you would have to in
order to make that work you would have
to imagine some modification of quantum
mechanics that made every macroscopic
superposition collapse very quickly so
there weren't any macroscopic
superpositions of matter and energy and
maybe you could do that but it's not at
all obvious how would would okay so why
would you never want to do something
like that I think we all know the answer
to that which is that when you try to
quantize gravity all hell breaks loose
Steve Karlin gave us a nice talk and how
you can do it in this extraordinarily
special case of two plus one dimensions
without any matter or anything like that
but more generally is hard and it's hard
for three different sets of reasons
number one the technical reasons it's
not a renormalizable Theory everything
is infinite it's hard to make
predictions number two there are
conceptual difficulties the nature of
time and especially the nature of space
is actually a big problem right the idea
of a local observable doesn't seem to
exist in general relativity because you
imagine that the metric itself takes on
different possible values let's say on
different branches of the wavefunction
reading language it's hard to save it to
identify the same point in two different
branches of the wavefunction so what is
locality even supposed to mean and
finally there are what we might call the
visceral objections to generosity being
quantized we think of space-time as the
arena in which things happen this is
clearly how Einstein thought you know
Einstein really had trouble wrapping his
mind around the idea that space-time was
anything other than the arena and now
you believe you quantized general
relativity spacetimes not that
fundamental he's the geometry of
space-time is not that fundamental now I
would argue that's not an especially
good argument I would argue that any
quantum theory devalues space-time as
the arena in which place things take
place because once you invention tangle
man you know that it's more like
configuration space or momentum space or
some other polarization of space and I
would further argue that if you really
liked and honor the values of quantum
mechanics you forget about space-time
altogether quantum states live in
hilbert space they're vectors in a
vector space in Hilbert spaces where
things happen and everything else is
just a useful way of talking so this
attitude is something that my
collaborators and I have taken to
extremes and something we call the mad
dog version of ever-ready in quantum
mechanics mad dog because many Eveready
ins still help themselves to a notion of
what the fundamental variables of the
theory are you're quantizing the
electromagnetic field in the drag field
or something like that
I think that's cheating I think we know
plenty of examples where there's two
different classical variables into
different classical theories which you
quantize and get the same quantum theory
quantum theory should be thought of as a
theory that lives
describes vectors in Hilbert space and
the right classical way to describe it
needs to emerge so that's what we're
working on so even space-time has to
emerge and the good news is you can kind
of see the outline of that how that
happens for a generic Hamiltonian you
wouldn't expect any local space-time
description but for very special
Hamiltonians there is a local space-time
description and when there is is more or
less unique and you can take that
space-time description just based on the
Hamiltonian just based on the spectrum
the eigen
use of the Hamiltonian and you can say
that if I had a state in that
Hamiltonian ol eyeing state near the
vacuum I can use the entanglement
structure of that state to define a
metric on space and perhaps on space
times and I can even argue that there's
an equation that that metric obeys and
that equation looks exactly like
Einsteins equation so this is very
speculative we're nowhere near filling
in all the blanks but it seems at least
plausible that rather than quantizing
gravity you can find gravity within
quantum mechanics given the right
Hamiltonian and the right state you see
that at the level of the semi-classical
approximation what is being described or
some fields propagating on a background
metric I think that's a very satisfying
way of doing things there's plenty of
problems with this the biggest single
problem is that we deal with locally
finite dimensional hilbert spaces which
makes it very difficult to implement
things like Lorentz invariance and
diffeomorphism invariance etc so we say
guess what those are not fundamental
they are emergent that may or may not
work this is what we're trying to do so
basically we are making all the visceral
problems of quantizing gravity harder
we're facing up to them by saying they
weren't problems at all you gonna have
to suck it up okay so the and this goes
very much
hand-in-hand with what I think is just
to sort of finish up this little rant
why do some people think quantum
mechanics is more fundamental and why
other people think general relativity is
more fundamental there is just as much
of a matter of taste here as a matter of
physics because you have to give up
something and the question is what are
you gonna give up right what what what
at which of your cherished beliefs or
your fundamental principles are going to
have to go and I remember vividly Lee
Smolin pointing out to me that there's a
strong correlation between people who
believed in the Everett interpretation
of quantum mechanics and people who
thought that computers could someday be
conscious and you wouldn't expect these
are very two very different kinds of
questions right but it's the same people
who light up and you know if you believe
in Everett you also believe that AI can
become conscious why is that well I
think that there's a there's an
explanation it depends on what you value
if you're never ready and you've learned
to accept what you value are very very
simple fundamental principles and what
you give up on is a very short direct
connection to the underlying fundamental
theory and the world of our experience
there might be many layers and many
different kinds of emergence and a lot
of project and work full employment to
be done in relating the simple
underlying principles to the world that
we see and that same kind of cast of
mind lets you think I don't really know
what consciousness is but I don't see
why the computer can't do it just as
well as a person where there's another
cast of mind that says consciousness is
something that I'm feeling in my brain I
can't even imagine a computer doing it
tables and chairs are something I see
they're located in space-time I don't
want to give up on them as fundamental
things I don't know which one is right
but I thank for the very same reasons
that I think that effort is a good
formulation of quantum mechanics that in
the battle between general relativity
and quantum mechanics general relativity
is going to be the one that ends up more
fundamental making his case for quantum
mechanics licensed quantum mechanic okay
well first thing I want to say is that
before I get into trying to defend do
you think that they kind of work but I
think that the kind of project that
Shawn is talking about is the most
valuable kind of project that we have in
the foundations of quantum mechanics
which is I don't think that we can
resolve the problem of the
interpretation of quantum mechanics
without trying to push these ideas into
new physics right so if
if mad dog have already it isn't turns
out to be right and Shawn has the
correct account of the emergence of
space-time and the emergence of gravity
then it will be very difficult to argue
that their variety and point of view is
wrong and so this is precisely the kind
of work we should be doing however what
they disagree on is how this is going to
play out
so the first thing is as Shawn mentioned
we have to interpret what the question
which is more fundamental quantum more
general relativity means so the way I
interpret this question is possibly a
bit different I'm not thinking that
we're going to end up with a theory
which has a class called metric well I
what we all agree on is that the
fundamental theory whatever it is has to
in the appropriate limit give us general
relativity and give us quantum field
theory in the standard model right so if
you want to call that theory quantum
gravity fine it may not turn out to be a
quantum theory or recognizable as a as
as a straightforward gravity theory but
it's some theory which has those things
as limit so the way I interpret the
question is in that theory will I
recognize principles that come from
general relativity as being its
foundation or will I recognize
principles that come from quantum
mechanics as being as foundation which
is which are more likely to be reliable
okay so I want to give two arguments for
thinking of principles from relativity
as being more fundamental the first one
is I think a fairly solid argument as
somebody who spends time thinking about
quantum foundations are definitely state
right in the second argument I'm going
to go way out of my comfort zone and and
be very speculative and talk about
things they didn't know very much about
so let's start with that so the first
thing is when I think about all this
fundamental theory what what kinds of
principles will it have will they have
principles from quantum mechanics or
principles from doing relativity well
both when I when I think about
possibility event having principles from
general relativity I think it's very
clear what those are at least you can
list some things that are important in
general relativity for example the idea
that gravity reduces to geometry the
idea that the equivalence principle that
grabbed that grant is equivalent to
acceleration in certain sense I wrote
down a few more here and for government
what they were let's see
yes equipments of different coordinate
systems that the laws of position
depends on new coordinate system etc so
you can write down these things and it's
sort of clear what they mean and it's
clear what they mean independent of the
mathematical framework - well of course
if I'm going to talk about gravity being
geometry I have to be talking about some
sort of geometry but it doesn't have to
be Romanian pseudo Romanian geometry
right if I formulate a discrete geometry
I can talk about what it would mean to
have a coordinate independent theory in
that geometry or if I even formulate a
noncommutative geometry I can talk about
what those principles would mean for
that geometry they are principles which
have broader than the specific
mathematical framework of differential
geometry that general relativity is
usually formulated it so although the
details the details of doing these
things are indeed extremely tricky right
to talk about what do you mean by the
retsoor diffeomorphism invariants in the
discrete geometry is a very difficult
thing but nonetheless I can think about
what those things mean and it seems to
make sense on the other hand what
principles quantum theory based on well
there are things that we tell
undergraduates they're based on or we
say the uncertainty principle is very
fundamental but I can't get any way in
the air deriving the mathematical
formalism of quantum theory from that
and also when you talk to different
physicists they will give you a
different list of things that are the
principles of quantum theory so some
might say oh it's the canonical
commutation relation it was always the
training require that we knows or it's
the structure of hilbert space all of
these things posited as fundamental
principles of quantum theory but they
are number one
very different depending on who you talk
to and number two usually very closely
tied to the mathematical formalism right
so if I say this fundamental theory is
gonna be so how quantum like does that
mean it has to be formulated in Hilbert
space it's difficult to say
so since possibly I mean there may be
there's more agreement in this room than
in general but generally speaking you
know I find it hard to understand what
even the principles of quantum theory
that is supposed to keep preserved in
this theory are right so I think if I'm
asking myself which of those two sets of
principles are more reliable as a guide
to constructing this theory I'm going to
choose the ones which I can I can
understand what they mean in a broader
framework so that's the first argument
so for those reasons I think general
turistic principles are more reliable
guides to very construction in the
second argument I'm going to get a bit
speculative I'm going basically I'm
willing to defend the idea or make the
prediction quantum theory will be long
gone before we get to the scale of
course of gravity and so I have to give
some reason even recorded so say that
there are of course people who believe
that quantum theory will break down for
various reasons usually the reason is
they won't solve the measurement problem
so if you think about the spontaneous
collapse theory for instance there will
be some size of macroscopic system at
which the rules of quantum theory break
down and we'll have a different theory
now I don't think that's the reason that
quantum theory will break down I think
that
it may make it replace by a theory
that's even weirder than corn some
Theory I don't think it's going to break
down in order to solve the measurement
problem but what I do think is that
there's an awfully large number of
orders of magnitude between the scale at
which we know quantum theory and quantum
field theory works and the Planck scale
right so it's quite to think that our
physical framework won't break down when
we get there it's quite as quite an
extrapolation specifically there are
problems in quantum field theories in
high energy physics that occur before we
even get to the Planck scale so this I
have to start looking at minus 4 so for
instance the grand unification scale is
believed to be about 3 orders of
magnitude smaller than the Planck scale
so about 10 to 25 electron volts verses
10 to 28 for the Planck scale as of now
the best bet for unification grand
unified theories of the three forces
have been supersymmetric theories in
which the coupling constants are
supposed to run together at that kind of
value all evidence that we have so far
suggests that those theories aren't the
right theories like the LHC has not
found any evidence for supersymmetry at
this point so right now we're in a limbo
where you know even though really how
grand unification is going to work for
the other three forces let alone gravity
now three orders of magnitude might not
seem that much so it might be that there
are effects that come from the Planck
scale that to thank that scale of
physics but there's still quite a quite
a large number
there's quite a large difference there
could be new physics that comes like you
know that scale that doesn't have
anything to do with Planck scale physics
and so high-energy physicists have got
really great model building trying
different kinds of symmetry groups
trying different kinds of ideas and but
they're all formulated within quantum
field theory like nobody has posited a
model that isn't quantum theoretical
order to try and solve these problems so
what I'm suggesting is that maybe there
there will be a theory that you know
reduces to quantum theory appropriately
but is somehow more general that comes
in somewhere around this scale and that
by the time we get to quantize it
gravity maybe we don't have something
that's recognizable as as quantum theory
after all so I let me give a very very
because you know I'm not an expert in
this area but I'll give you a an idea
for an idea so in the foundations of
quantum mechanics we have studied there
is at a more general than quantum theory
specifically in the framework of
generalized probabilistic theories
within the last few decades one of the
things that you find in those theories
is that the structure of the state
spaces can be very different from the
helmet space and in particular the way
the way in the relationships between
numbers of parameters work can be
different so you can talk about the
number of states that can be perfectly
distinguished in a theory that's some
number let's call it D and you can talk
about the number of parameters required
to specify a state of a theory let's
call that number n in quantum theory you
have the relationship N equals d squared
but you can there is in which this is
very different now n is basically the
dimension of the vector space in which
your your theorem is so the thing is one
of the one of the things that you need
when you're building a grand unified
theory is you need space in which a
representation of york grand unified
symmetry group is going to act if you
assume standard Hilbert space courts of
mechanics you have you are restricted to
talking about unitary representations on
the hilbert space if we started talking
about representations of groups on these
more generous spaces we could have
indeed more parameters to play with more
parameters more different kinds of
representations that we could try and
look at and maybe this is extremely
speculative but maybe you could get some
kind of unification without needing
supersymmetry or maybe you could make a
prediction which could be verified in
the near term so that's just that's just
one speculative idea extremely
speculative but I think the general
point is that there's a large number of
order of magnitude still to go the idea
of modifying quantum theory in order to
solve these kinds of problems hasn't
really been tried because the people
who've been trying to
understand these kinds of theories
haven't haven't commented from a sort of
foundational background we're modifying
quantum theory is even on the table so
if I'm going to make a prediction I
think the principles of general
relativity will survive up until that
scale but the principles of quantum
theory if we can even agree what they
are won't necessarily survive I don't
think there are reliable games for
building like we briefly you spawn
before we open it up so um I actually
think in your second point where you
point out that there are things we don't
understand yet and exploring the
possibility modifying quantum mechanics
might be a sensible strategy I agree
with the motivation I think that
modifying quantum mechanics is probably
a longshot strategy but that's some
extent a matter of taste I do think that
modifying on a field theory makes
perfect sense because many of these
problems are up near where gravity
becomes important and quantum mechanical
and if I'm right about the finiteness of
the hilbert space that describes local
regions of space-time in quantum gravity
then quantum field theory is going to
give out they might give out long before
you reach the Planck scale even though
it's still fully QFT if I make you a
glass of wine yeah quantum field theory
QFT will give out but quantum mechanics
I think could still be perfectly valid
to address some of these questions to
your first point yes and no I mean
certainly at face value the principles
of general relativity which is part of
the fact that is the most beautiful
physical theory are crystal clear we all
agree on them they're not big debates on
the interpretations of general
relativity the principles of quantum
mechanics as you point out there's not a
consensus on what they are but there are
options for what they might be and I
would say that if any one of those
options whether it is some bohmian view
or many worlds or TRW or something
epistemic if that's what turns out to be
right in the ultimate unification of
quantum mechanics and gravity I would
still declare victory in the debate
today certainly if it doesn't turn out
to be
I'm ready in point of view then I would
declare victory but I would ask the real
point in getting to is that you say
correctly that in gr we have a geometry
you could imagine that a better theory
of gravity it might not be the pseudo
Romani in geometry that we have in
general relativity 100% opined that
that's very interesting I've tried it
myself but do I take from that the
implication that you think there will be
a geometry rather than a wavefunction of
geometries or a superposition of
geometries well I mean I don't know what
they'll be absolutely I mean I mean I am
a scientist M assists so I don't think
that but that the wavefunction Hilbert
space quantum states on the Hilbert
space is fundamental in many sense right
so this is one sense in which I think
you know if if this kind of view is
right and I develop this a scientist a
mikvah you into a fully interpretation
of quantum mechanics and then I say okay
what does that mean for what does that
mean for gravity then the result of that
I think might not be recognizable as
something that you'd want to call the
quantum theory because I'm going to say
the fundamental degrees of freedom I
mean I may end up using more or less
none of the mathematical structure of
quantum theory in their theory so I'm
not I mean I guess it's a question of
technology but I'm not sure that that if
I accomplish that goal you really would
say that thing that you've derived is
recognizable as a quantum theory in some
sense so it's not clear I would also say
to the other point you know we do have
you know at least half a dozen
interpretations of quantum theory that
work I don't think we have half a dozen
different sets of principles underlying
quantum theory don't work because the
way that most interpretations group work
is that they take the map
there's a quantum theory of some place
values represent at least most realistic
interpretation taking us at face value
is representing no we don't need to have
another derivation of the Schrodinger
equation from some principles residence
we take that mathematical formalism as
face value and then we add things to it
or we try to interpret it as of Tears we
don't try to in general foundation the
foundations of quantum mechanics in
terms of physical principles like the
ones in terms of general relativity so
even if bohmian say bohmian mechanics
turns out to be right I think it's still
being sort of hard pressed to say
exactly what the principles of quantum
theory are in a way that everybody would
would agree in the way that would be
non-controversial to the same extent
that you went in in general relativity
so it's it's not sort of a question of
maybe one interpretations right and the
other ones wrong well I'm trying to
point to is that you know they don't
seem to be these these founded
principles that we could get any kind of
consensus it's gonna be on the record of
saying that makes me very sad that I am
on the stuffy conservative side of the
debate I would much rather be the
radical bomb thrower but conscious
forbids me in this particular
[Applause]
okay
in some sense general relativity is a
very special it's a period of special
the spatial representation unitary
principle of superposition representing
properties in terms
basis and so there's a cluster of jets
shared needs of parents so I think we
are on the track I don't know what the
next generation
I agree so I mean one thing I want to
say is that I mean it's not I mean okay
so the idea here is that the way look at
it quantum quantum mechanics or quantum
theory is a frame you look for variety
of theories general relativity is one
very specific theory I do agree with
that but it's not and it's not quite
true you can talk about framework you
can talk about theories though - a bit
different from general relativity and
satisfy similar principles you can talk
about some of the general framework of
differential geometric like theories
that satisfy some of these theories and
some of these entire alternatives have
been investigated but indeed have been
investigated but there's a framework for
things that are possible alternatives to
general relativity and there's an
understanding of what kinds of evidence
it takes to rule them out there as you
see the situation in quantum theory is
much less than that it is more - well I
mean it's like the range the range of
theories that's a quantum light not
exactly quantum mechanics but quantum
like is completely you know I mean there
are various frameworks talking about it
but in terms of pushing them to the
point where we can say okay here's the
experiment where this one would make a
different prediction from that one and
this is where we expect it to happen
it's much less well well explored that
than in the case of general relativity
in general relativity there was a
concerted program starting in the
nineteen fifties to try and
experimentally determine whether this
theory was really true and some people
really
the idea of these alternatives and we
haven't had that same degree of rigor
and understanding this in quantum
mechanics so in the sense to me what
you're saying seems precisely the wrong
way around
we have territory we have extremely
understand nearly as well as we
understand it might as well as we
understand key CD or something we can
calculate in it so I'm so sure it's not
that we have it's not we have in between
at just the level of those dudes
themselves we have - implants shovel but
there's a perfectly happy peaceful
coexistence between general relativity
if we decide it's not direct evidence
but if we were to decide upon best
features then it seems the need to
modify quantum mechanics knowledge
education scales scales of I mean if we
just picked up something essentially if
we if we what if you want to say how it
is that I've got an ordinary get a
process whereby articles trying
criterion enzyme position this time hole
if we try to put for instance the
expected values like areas
so I even modify quantum mechanics so as
to collapse the wave function which is
an honorable starting to play but it's a
race to the states pretty dramatically
all we say we need to guess where this
comes into the babies I don't I don't
think
but if we want to modify or mechanics so
as the whole octopus copy to captivity
this is again if you're dumb yes this is
a Christian but you were saying what you
didn't think we should exactly so I
guess it takes as a question to matter
guess how we do how we think about
morality of the ordinary macroscopic
situations and instead of decadence
classical chaos context it deliberately
didn't argue that I think gravity should
be under quantized they deliberately
didn't argue that I think we the theory
in which you have a definite space-time
with a definite metric tensor and was
fundamental I was rather making a
different argument as to the principles
of which theory are more reliable going
to very building so I totally agree with
with with what you're saying of course
you know being somebody who's somewhat
place to people who are trying to build
quantum computers I thoroughly believe
in the idea that you can get an
arbitrary large system into coherent
macroscopic superposition and once
you're at that position and you think
that you can have super positions of
mass
at least mesoscopic scale and the idea
that gravity has quantum features is
obviously true so when I when I really
arguing is gravity which is exact going
to nature I mean to say yeah I agree
that could happen and that would be very
happy about this isn't Shawn's position
and it's also the mainstream position in
in physics people who are taking like
string theory based approaches they also
think that gr is essentially an emergent
it's because Quan gravity's hard and we
have clues from things like black hole
information that seem to be pointing us
in a direction that says that at the
deepest level general relativity is not
there it could be wrong
I was showing you when you were saying
whenever interpretation of quantum
mechanics turns out to be right I still
could win so I just it's not your
scientists team at the home state is
talking about I guess the way I was
thinking that it was more along the
lines would some of the things we
currently think about these theories
need to be abandoned in this more
fundamental theory so I think that math
is very young bravely says that he's
actually imagining that when we try to
solve problems like the hierarchy
problem grand unification maybe the
cosmos the constant problem quantum
mechanics is really gonna have to be
modified from any of its current
formulation and so I would include an
epistemic version in that thing that
would need to be modified is that fair
or do you where's your epistemic it's
very easy for me to say these things by
the way because I know next
think about these problems that's a
quote slavery yeah if I you know I may
at some point like looking more detail
into these things it's not - its program
right now and I'm sure I will find very
big problems with everything I've
suggested but nonetheless that's the
proposal yeah I mean to me in quantum
gravity in the standard ways I can think
about it locality is not fundamental
whereas in general relativity or even in
quantum field theory it is so in my view
how gravity wall Tinley be quantized
this important feature of general
relativity is going to have to go and I
take the important features of quantum
mechanics library to quantum mechanics
to be was a state in the hilbert space
that evolves unitarily and everything
else is emergent with that and that will
be exactly true in the ultimate theory
is my guess so that's the sense in which
I'm giving up on something from do you
are
I mean I would say I mean I think that
correctly says that we had this program
for decades now of modifying general
relativity and testing it empirically in
a way that we don't have an analogous
program for quantum mechanics I would
suggest it's because quantum mechanics
is in some sense very fragile if you
change it at all it breaks immediately
and is ruled out and that is a feature
of Ponemah case it's a good feature
general relativity is all loosey goosey
some fields and you write down some
Agron gian and anything can happen and
why it's this particular thing why there
isn't some massless dilettante field we
all know there's all sorts of other
things that could have been whereas
quantum mechanics it like all the
theories ever it seems to be that the
fundamental framework of it is not
optional like here it is the
Schrodinger's equation when there's
hilbert space this is like this I
totally disagree I mean I think there
definitely is a tradition of multiplying
quantum mechanics and things like that
where you seem to show as soon as you
make it tiny changed right all hell
breaks loose again superluminal
signaling and things like this but this
is because these these modifications
were done by people who were not
particularly sophisticated on the
meaning of the various terms in quantum
theory in particular you know if you
list the axioms of quantum theory one of
the things when the I think the biggest
lesson that we've learned from the
foundations of quantum theory is that
those mathematically independent axioms
are not in fact physically independent
right so you can't just go and change
the
an equation without also changing the
measurement crossness is inconsistent
and a lot of this generalization work
has been done in not thinking about
these things in a very sophisticated way
and you know we've shown that in the
last decades that in principle it's
possible to have probabilistic
frameworks which are more general than
either classical or quantum they exist
we don't know how to formulate real
physical theories in them but it's
possible to do it in a way that doesn't
violate their signaling and things like
that I mean that seems to say he's wait
to change abstract framework but here's
how you determine such as this is yeah
we don't even have much more basic
things like that such as how to what's
really the full full understanding of
the way to represent symmetry groups and
this kind of thing how do you represent
time translation and general and things
like that
so this isn't it this is not well
understood and it may be that all of
these theories are complete but of
course there may also be much more
radical modifications of quantum theory
that have to happen other than that like
it could be that our most fundamental
theory won't predict precisely miracle
probabilities for instance that's
something there isn't usually on the
table or you know you can think of many
other kinds of structures that we
usually think of as it's just obviously
having to be true might not be so so I
think there is there's a lot of scope
there there's maybe not
a great physical reason for thinking
that doing any of this will solve any
specific one problem of I mean the only
one that there's any real way to the
patient for is sort of discretization as
a whole and there's some motivation for
doing that coming from quantum gravity
but all I'm fighting out is that there
is at least a large space of logically
consistent possibilities that don't
necessarily lead to pathologies that
could potentially dissolve some of these
problems
it's worth thinking about and we haven't
thought about it because the people who
they're looking at these things are very
sophisticated about quantum field theory
and the people who are yeah quantum
field theory aren't sophisticated about
this stuff so there's a little bit of a
culture gap there but there's no real
reason not to try and push this
good I just want to perspect that I'm
Matt's claim we don't have as
fundamental principles for quantum
mechanics as we do for Chiara or hope to
so two examples I wanted to put out so
I'll agree the fact we have this
workshop is an example that of course
it's controversial so not resolved but
being an optimist at least two examples
that I hope that we converge on is some
resolution around the gauge principle
which does a whole lot of work in theory
building when you want to talk about
like a single principle that like
unifies like why we have horses does a
whole lot of work so you want to talk
about want to talk about a principle
it's gonna survive theory change gauge
principle is way out there
representation theory and just groups in
general which definitely play a big role
in gr but like yeah they play unique
role in quantum mechanics that's going
to survive in a way out I think we fully
said as a group
choose things that I would hope that we
may clarify better thank you I have to
say I you largely agree with you yeah I
mean there is sort of pushing some
quarters to move away from symmetries
and representations as being fundamental
but with his obviously wooden base
successful programs in all of physics
and I think I think that it's it's not
obvi Smith each principal will suppose
but it is a candidate so I'm generally
sympathetic with Shawn's viewpoint here
although I have to admit it's partly
because I don't know very much about
modifications of quantum mechanics that
don't break it but something I should
learn about but I have a couple of
reservations one has to do with exactly
what you mean by quantum mechanics or
quantum theory survivin I think that
there are actually very good arguments
that the Hilbert space picture is not
going to survive that come from these
results of Torian ver aren't Florida
Roger that
even for a flat space-time free scalar
field that different choices of time
slicing give you unitarily in equivalent
hilbert spaces you can fit that all in
what I would still call quantum
mechanics but in an algebraic framework
and not a Hilbert space framework so
depending on which parts of quantum
mechanics you're willing to give up in
which parts you aren't
I think the answers might differ the
other thing is that it scares me to
death to here to T there you say that
you think that diffeomorphism invariance
is going to be an approximate than
emergent symmetry because without
diffeomorphism invariance you don't have
the right degrees of freedom and there's
no sensible way to enforce to keep the
graviton massless as soon as you give up
diffeomorphism invariance it's
equivalent to giving up gauge invariance
in about your magnetism any
perturbations would give you mass to the
photon keeping it strictly massive us
either either either diffeomorphism in
variances there or something magical
happens that somehow remarkably exactly
reproduces the results of differing
orphism invariance to arbitrarily high
orders and I just don't believe
yeah Weinberg Wickham theorem and all
sorts of well I don't think someone into
the Weinberg wind theorem but it's
because you've already done something
worse which is you discretized and have
a five dimensional hilbert space so you
don't have perfect Lorentz invariants of
you know the white rabbit okay yeah but
still you're right that getting things
to be massless whether the photons of
gravitons seem miraculous from this
point of view the fact that we don't
have easily phenomenologically
noticeable violations of Lorentz
invariants seems of very surprising from
this point of view so and that's why I
always emphasize that this is the big
looming problem in the whole program I
don't know how to get things like black
hole entropy and de sitter entropy right
if I have an infinite number of degrees
of freedom which is the only way I know
how to get special relativity exactly
right so something has to go I don't
think in either case it's quantum
mechanics that has to go but I think
many people have been pushing on keeping
diffeomorphism invariants and hoping the
black holes in the center space work out
okay it's worth some plucking minority
of us pushing on the other possibility
okay I hoped argue with that and my
heart goes more with but just think and
they get these very suggestive things
though but you know two considerations
one is I mean this is really a thigh man
the stress-energy tensor and again this
is late evening sort of thing you just
seem so phenomenological the you know
equation but maybe it's just screaming
out its phenomenological Ness it doesn't
seem like I sort of candidate to be the
fundamental thing and then I was
wondering whether it was useful to think
about you know any particular particular
experiments that particularly cases that
would you know we suggested one way
rather than the other and the one that
was thinking it was the cow experiments
so we have the neutron that's broke that
your parameters and then the wave
function except the wave function then
depends on the mass and whether that and
I subsisted awkwardly with this sort of
idea that the wave function would so
look freely from the plate if I need to
talk about both of those things
I do understand the second thing at all
what do you want a cow expert yeah what
is your but what about it well well they
are lend well they're thinking about
those lends support one way rather than
the other so there you have some sense
that you have you know there's a need
for moving in a gravitational field
right quantum gravity what it's not
quantum grando
yeah so the question is whether dis
advised some breaking of the principle
of equivalence because the wavefunction
the face of the wave function is not
mean I think the principle Combs is very
overrated it was a great way to be
inspired to invention a relativity at
the end of the day general relativity is
the Einstein Hilbert action plus some
matter terms and everything comes out of
it so you just do that and you get the
answer whatever the answer is is
consistent with what you've been doing
[Laughter]
[Music]
so what was exactly the claim
it's it's a neutron interferometry
experiment in which the two paths move
through occasional field at different
heights
that's that depends on the gravitational
field so that demonstrates gravity
gravitational classical gravitational
field does have an observable effect on
the quantum behavior of neutrons but to
people that the thing that people
sometimes worry about is that the phase
shift and therefore this quantum effect
would be different if you do it's
different if you do it with neutrons or
hydrogen atoms saying depends on the
mass there are claims that that shows a
violation it shows a violation I mean so
I can imagine that you say there are
other things that go along the lines of
if you have a free electron and proton
they move in certain ways and when you
put them together to make a hydrogen
atom
now there's binding energy or there's a
difference in binding energy and the
principle of equivalence would have that
binding energy couple the same as any
other energy to the gravitational field
is that the kind of arguments you know
it's more that I mean there's a jinx it
but there's a control of interference
that says look the way feelings behave
in gravitational fields is the TPMS so
with the interference of the neutron the
gravitation
electro gravitational field is a mass
term in on that particular very crude
conception will be feelings principle is
really very defensible okay that seems
to me the correct equivalence principle
is number one
I can choose coordinates in which the
metric number two there's no there's no
definitely definitely definitely sort of
I mean at the corner of 50 there seems
to be okay so as a scientist emesis I
have to kind of make an objection here
which is like the people tend to think
that either there's the wavefunction
which in an interferometer spreads out
along two paths or there's not the
wavefunction there's a particle which
goes one way or the other but that's
that's not so you can still even if
you're a scientist emesis you can have
that the ontological degrees of freedom
are spread out and in fact if you want
to reproduce interference as it
precisely what you have is just that
these degrees of freedom aren't enough
to reconstruct what the wave function is
so the idea that you get a different
interference pattern depending on the
mass you know
doesn't really bother me because that
mess whatever it is can be spread out
some of those two paths and we produce
that apparent I mean I'm not bothered by
that any more than I'm bothered by a
usual mach-zehnder interferometer which
I know how to reproduce in you you said
that you were said that you couldn't I
guess I guess my heart is with my -
here's the thing I mean
I wanted asking for Sean's original
comments which was about the status
lines and two other patients so where do
you see those going the teacher you talk
about some principles of gr that you
want to hold on to what's going to
happen to incentive
I mean I I mean I don't know what the
final Theory looks like what
mathematical framework is formulated in
so exactly what happens to those I don't
know I am fond of well I mean this sort
of comes from my affinity with some of
the things that can like to talk about
as well I am fond of thinking about the
field equations as opposed to thinking
about ER in terms of actual principles
right they tend to think of as being
what general relativity maybe is
including the solutions with place
timelike curves and things like I
consider that to be part of general
relativity so I think thinking about the
Einstein field equations is probably
more in line with where I think the
theory is going to go in and thinking
about the Einstein Hill protection
principles
I mean people they say it's sort of
thank you really understand this point
about the marble versus wood business
it's like people concerned that F equals
MA that M is horrible or something I
mean what what's wrong with this I mean
it's it's the thing that generates the
we have very beautiful clean
descriptions general relativity where
the right hand side is generating
familiar branches and that appeal is
very beautiful in the regime where we
actually test
so the claim is that you would like a
cleaner derivation is please just saying
if you believe if you think as Matt
doesn't want to do general relativity is
coming from the action principle the
niceness of the left-hand side is simply
reflection of there aren't that many
scalar functions you can write down for
the metric there's just one that lowest
order right and then it's pretty
determined at first order at most order
that's right yes
whereas there seems to be a lot more
arbitrariness and lagrangians you can
write down on the right-hand side which
is okay but it's still there is this
mathematical operation I've learned
where I can take one side of an equation
and move it to the other by subtraction
so they're both on the same side and
they're both the functional derivatives
back to the metric I don't really see
the difference so you're right Chandan
just about every piece given what we
really shouldn't know better we really
should have known better to keep time
separate from space-time space-time we
really should know better talk about
States on instantaneous surfaces we
should have known better talk about
operators operating on the state science
and pain services we should have known
better to go back to the original
motivation of the Turner equation which
was to do things it took they took the
hamilton-jacobi action which doesn't
leave us response it's an integral and
it's integral to the point that is now
assuming that you measure it there and
then you can compact all that and say
there's my state even though if you
don't measure it there it goes on and
that wasn't the action at all we should
know better than to go to configuration
space from stop map which we knew was
not a real thing and say this is the
framework when we can clearly see where
we're shooting or stolen from Stephanie
it was obviously and so we took all
these things that we should know better
to put them together and now we have
this tiny box and sure enough
but it seems to me that what we do is
alternate without success that's where
our best matches to data Oh what the
shorter equation gives us these
probabilities that we've dumbed down
when the thing is a good prediction when
I think you talking very historically
about where we bought but but I think
that you're then doing disservice to the
final product which regardless of the
frankensteining away which was assembled
it's not actually a bunch of different
pieces fit together it's a quite compact
sleep me machine of each burger equation
acting on vectors in hilbert space and
it's hard to mess with it and I would
further say in the gr versus quantum
mechanics thing we haven't even
mentioned the word singularities and one
problem with all classical mechanics
classical mechanics is enormous ly more
complicated than quantum mechanics
because quantum mechanics is linear so
classical mechanics you can run into
singularities at the boundary of
configuration space in quantum mechanics
h sy equals i D by DT sy and if you
think of it the way I want to think of
it as you know you're a vector in
hilbert space with a Hamiltonian right
sy in the energy eigenbasis and all that
ever happens in quantum mechanical
evolution is the face of every little
energy eigenstate rotates so all of your
evolution no matter how complicated your
system is is moving on a straight line
in a little torus and it will never end
it will go on forever it's mediate and
it's pretty and there's no singularities
and everything is great and you guys
want to give up on that I don't know
because that's because if you're if
you're if you're really if you feel
hilbert space in your bones you do not
think of it as a set of square root of
all functions of configurations you
think of it as a vector that's doing
something and so that classical
probability distribution is necessarily
publius tribution on classical things
that could go singular whereas the
quantum vector is just moving around in
a little circle it's much nice well I
think I think all that emerges that's no
longer conversation but yeah okay
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I want to say first of all the
causality is an interesting program I
think it's an interesting program I have
some sympathy for it but I think that
your historical argument there was
misguided because you could say the same
thing about almost any physical theory
in the history of science
yeah I mean look good look at Newton's
inspirations for coming up with
classical mechanics he was you know a
magpie you pick things up from you know
all sorts of strange places and it
shouldn't work you know I mean he was
beautiful calmly the last alchemists of
the last magician I did not get bashed
classical mechanics because you know you
think that [ __ ] from all sorts of places
and he decided you know I'm gonna like
I'd say it would be crazy adversity but
you know something proportional to B
squared is conserved and something
proportional to B is also conserved
ready to give them different pans like
their back that wasn't perfectly
I know but what I'm saying is that you
know that attack all these things
together right so this is a fun
conversation there's wandering away but
I move that we stop the video and
declare victory and then gather around